now for Asian cooking is really big bold
flavors and it's really a study of
history I travel to Ghana we really
developed this cuisine of Afro Asian
cooking where there's nowhere else in
the country right now
I'm Joseph JJ Johnson executive chef of
the Cecil Minton's in Harlem New York
today I'm gonna bring to you chicken and
dumplings with a Riesling curry sauce
the dish is amazing for the holidays
because it's gonna really bring your
family together it just reminds me of
like my family in the kitchen
everybody's like how can I help you what
can I do so let's start with the chicken
thighs
I believe in salt and pepper and a lot
of love we're gonna go right into the
pan right here I add in a little bit of
thyme right on top my hair o matic one
or two cinnamon sticks
two bird eye chilli four spice and then
some lemongrass and the cubed lemongrass
you have to actually bang it to get out
to get out the flavor
and then you'll put in the oven at 350
degrees for about one hour so now we're
gonna go into the reason curry sauce
while the chicken is cooking we're gonna
toast this garlic so that we can get
some nice sweetness to toast for about
30 seconds the curry and then we'll add
in about two tablespoons of tomato paste
and then the best part of the dish the
reason why about a half a bottle you can
drink the other half while you're doing
this doing the holiday times so we're
gonna strain the liquid right into all
of our ingredients that are in the pot
now we'll take the sauce ingredients and
blend everything together I add in the
lemon juice throw in the butter
all right so now we have our braised
chicken super tender super flavorful
we're gonna add in some 1/2 a cup of oil
and the final thing is we're just adding
all of our chicken and then we're just
going to incorporate it all together
that's really nice
grab your dumpling skins a nice pinch of
the mix and you'll brush around the
outside and then this is the key
gogo corn in a corner you want to make
sure it's sealed really tight it should
look like this and then you want to take
a little bit of egg wash in the backside
of the dumpling here pinch the back and
fold in that's how you want it to look
when they become translucent that's when
you know they're done for your holiday
party to put them right in a nice
communal bowl where everybody can share
a nice amount of sauce and then you can
garnish it some micro cilantro and there
you go chicken and dumplings Riesling
curry micro cilantro